john thys plus écoutées en ce moment
c'est google plein festival sur le ps
store c'est à dire qu'il ya plein de
réduction sur plein de jeux et j'ai
trouvé brendon parmi ces jeux ça sert
totalement à rien ce que chez autre
affaire puisque le gameplay à l'écran
voilà l'homme tombé on va devoir être
intelligent qu'on joue à ce jeu le
principe est très simple vous allez voir
bon c'est pas un quiz coup que la
dernière fois si jamais il faut juste
voyez faire un trait comme ceux ci
auraient une autre et se solidifient
faut réunir les deux boules
voilà c'est le genre de jeu à la con sur
lesquels tu peux passer cinq heures
voilà logiquement il suffit de les
entourer
elles vont se retrouver un jour et
et hop la [ __ ] intelligence donc
l'appareil il faut faire tomber juste ça
comme ça oh la la c'est on peut faire un
trop plein du coup ouais comme ça on a
perdu la guerre aux plastiques ruth gisi
et on gagne lol je suis retombé ça aux
plats aux plats faciles
c'est génial comme principe on m'a très
fière de ce jeu comme des gros porcs et
les suivants ça dégage bien sûr on line
extreme harbaoui à la bassée perdu c'est
rattrapable c'est rattrapable sata pas à
vous regarder c'est rattrapable c'est
rattrapable c'est rattrapable
ok je pose si on fait ça ça marchera
moment de vérité bon ben spies pas ben
voilà tacheté pas sur un jdc part a
choisi le mec je suis tout sauf un allez
allez allez allez allez allez allez
allez
et tellement marrant fais comme tu as
l'air aux dires des tétons ou des gros
tu étais vous avez vu pour la classe à
l'euro on essaie de mettre de la
difficulté à ce que je vois jackson
merde merde voilà allez on y va
quoi mais non tout ça pète la gueule
shebab au poste des modems à nice ont
raté de peu au c'était une scène
tellement oh oh oh oh liste et même dans
la bouche [ __ ] un battant mais je crois
qu'en fait j'ai trouvé comment
totalement carotte que je suis juste ça
à chaque fois ça marche pas on fait quoi
regardez j'ai tué le jeu on a tué la
matrice bas oblige il avait prévu le
coup ah ça c'est simple ça voilà aurait
tué la matrice au cette belle impulsion
qu'on a fait là à l'etivaz aussi madame
est beaucoup plus dense à quoi parfait
allez on y va
oh [ __ ] oh la la non sinon tu te tais
pas s'en servir comme ça mais c'est pas
moi c'est l'ultra les ce que j'ai fait
c'est quoi ce délire
ah ok donc la grille m'empêche de
dessiner de danfoss dessine au dessus
aux difficultés accrues
spock ohlala ça c'était beau c'était
archi beau regarder j'ai fait un point
que j'aime pas fait exprès du coup la
boule elle va pouvoir y aller du coup la
boule va pouvoir y aller
du coup la boule elle va pouvoir y aller
alors là le talent d'un homme non non je
te sors j'ai pas eu le temps de le
sauver c'est vrai j'ai tout faire pour
ça c'est les femmes ça on fait tout poil
elle se bat au tapis les violents la
[ __ ] veille les tapis sont plus ou
moins violents et si on fait juste
ben c'était bien de la merde la grosse
merde au nom jusqu'en fait ça sa griffe
sur le bord du tapis pas du tout comme
ça oui et 2 mois il a dit je craque
voilà tu es c'est un truc du genre
j'avais raison bah non non je suis
désolé mais non c'est de la merde bras
mais non mais la blague même avec l'aide
j'y arrive pas je suis en train de
devenir fou là non mais c'est trop dur
le flop est un jeu fait péter un câble
mec j'ai une aide
veux tu te laisses comme c'était en
train de mourir je te dis tu veux de
l'aide tu me dis oui et j'ai pas deux
fois cette blague ta gueule tagolsheim
c'est google c'est google qui me dit la
solution c'est google grosse mer
normalement ça marche avec l'aide merci
google mais mais mais bonjour je suis
dacc maul et fait exploser ce jeu voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà ça c'est
un doigt d'honneur ça voilà tiens on va
faire un truc ce qui les deux ours alors
ça c'est pour vous monsieur ça c'est
pour toi le mec qui a écrit l'est de
l'amo que sous les dettes vous regardez
cette vidéo voilà le haut mais ok si je
touche du truc l'air je meurs alors là
je tente un truc ça fait un crash mais
ça marche normalement voilà la puissance
des crabes
oap les verts mon gars c'est beau bon
voilà alors là dans un silence complet
très bons moments tout dans la mouvance
dans le skill on entoure à la technique
de l'entourage à baddeck feu et
compagnie vous voulez qu'ils ont fait
comme en dix jours et que feu
l'entourage là son groupe l'a entouré le
jeu drop red dot audiard dont patrick
sébastien la en trois coups ou noces
merde
non mais là c'était pas prévu ça comment
faire merde
là tu as trop lourd trop long anna non
au nom est là mais non mais je fais
tellement on est tous tenus à mais n'en
avais dégage mais nulle lâche y est
presque
oh non on fait comment quand c'est comme
ça à chaud mais qu'attend est je suis
trop con mlg pro 1 1 2 là en haut ça va
peser lourd ibos au rouge en presque à
maintenant oh là là tu utilises or les
calculs dans la vie de mathématiques de
merde
ok alors hop show tout le monde puisse
au ce style de malade mon gars je peux
plus m'arrêter d'oise plus d'un dieu je
sais que vous avez envie là deux
thielles outreau que vous cliquez sur
suivant pour voir notre vidéo clash peux
plus m'arrêter ok il en va de je ne sais
pas j'arrive pas aller au filet sur
celui là parce que celles rencontrées
belle au centre de la map
ça veut dire je suis fort à brendon en
latin je fais l'opéra royal jean s'est
bien passé on présente ça fait du bien
de faire un petit jeu tablette comme ça
où il faut réfléchir
voilà ça lui mais aussi dans tous mes
états mais ça bon c'est normal je fais
ça va plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo que d'habitude
et puis écoutez on se retrouve tout de
suite pour une autre vidéo sur brendon
et puis encore une après et puis
dimanche aussi on voit ça dans une foire
m'en faut arrêter un messier perdit ctif
ces [ __ ] de tablettes comme et
n'apportent des foyers des jeux vraiment
nulle où tu joues un pixel qui dois je
sais pas trouvé une vache laitière et tu
as passé de 10 heures dessus ça n'a
aucun sens la vie en 2015 présentant
tamesna deux prochaines vidéos vers 7h
au regard de chat pis